but arguably his greatest achievement
and the second of the two poems he's
most famous for is an absolutely
breathtaking poem known as ataya El
kubra basically the great ode rhyming in
the letter tar also known as nasma suluk
the poem of the Sufi way
this is often considered the longest
mystical poem in the Arabic language
with a whopping
761 verses
but it isn't just famous for its length
but also for being one of the most
profound expressions of the mystical
path and divine Oneness ever put into
words the first section of the poem
expresses how the poet seeks Union with
his beloved which is God
the poem expresses this experience of
unity and Oneness throughout in
different ways and in different stages
here the poet has become completely
annihilated become entirely intoxicated
and effaced in the reality of God where
there is no trace of Multiplicity or
self at all